[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUBJECT: The internet
dubbed this the hottest kiss
in the world, and
it's easy to see why.
The couple locked
in a passionate kiss
are standing right next
to a field of molten lava
in the pouring rain.
This is what it looks like when
two daredevil photographers
decide to take a
romantic selfie.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DALLAS NAGATA WHITE: Hi, my
name is Dallas Nagata White.
ED WHITE: And I'm Ed White.
DALLAS NAGATA WHITE: And we
are professional photographers
living in Honalulu, Hawaii.
ED WHITE: This photo was
taken in the Kalapana
area of the big island Hawaii.
Ironically, it's not the
photo we set out to take.
SUBJECT: The duo wanted to
capture an image that showed
off Kalapana's fiery landscape.
Though first, that involved
walking directly into
said fiery landscape.
ED WHITE: The hike to the actual
flow was a surreal experience,
and lava is nothing
like what you think.
The cool rock is actually
really, really fluffy
because of all the
dissolved gases.
So the landscape itself
dampens all the sound around,
and the only thing you can
here are your companions
and the crunch crunch crunch
of the soft rock giving away
beneath your feet
as you hike over it.
SUBJECT: Finally, after three
hours of hiking, Dallas and Ed
made it to this is spot, only
the shot they had in mind
wasn't going to be possible as
it suddenly started to rain.
ED WHITE: Luckily I had
hiked in some strobes
and some wireless
triggers, and we
decide to try to trick that we
had used several times before.
Our friends insisted
that we should
have our photos taken too.
So we posed in
front of the strobe
and put our hands on our hips.
And I felt like I needed a
little bit something more.
So I whisper into Dallas' ear,
like, hey, let's do one more.
And without telling her, I
dipped her and kissed her,
and then the strobe went off.
And that picture
came into existence.
SUBJECT: For Dallas
and Ed, this image
is the most epic reminder
of a unique place.
ED WHITE: In many ways,
hiking out to Kalapana
was a very humbling experience.
You just can't help but respect
the Earth's awesome power
at just moves along
whether or not
humanity is moving
along with it.
And you just come
away with a sense
of just how everything
is so temporary
and how the Earth is
always renewing itself
whether we're coming
along for the ride or not.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
For even more Seeker stories,
click on the Subscribe button
here so you never
miss an episode.
Thanks for watching.